dann ist der dritte kinder leute und der
dritte kill heißt dass ich euch den
dritten einkaufszeit muss ich heute
sagen weil ich nicht die sachen der
dritte ein kauf sind herzlich willkommen
zu einer neuen folge minecraft heute
spielen wir eine runde krise walls hier
mit dem rad aber nicht nur mit markt
sondern heute auch noch mit einer
richtig witzigen challenge wie ich finde
uns war war ich heute einkaufen
ja ich hab grad frau ihr besuch von
freunden deswegen habe ich mich ein
bisschen um regelmäßig videos gemacht
normalerweise kämen heute video schon
früher jetzt ist ab 10
wenn wir das hier aufräumen aber die
challenge ist cool und zwar hab ich
natürlich lieber titel ist ja sowieso
nennen marielle krieges es gibt mir
klicks und zwar werden wir heute eine
wie marx sagt du bist die persistenz
oder anders formuliert eine hohe talent
machen das heißt ich zeige euch für
jeden kill den ich im deathmatch mache
ein meine einkäufe die ich heute gemacht
habe und ich habe eigentlich schon ganz
gut eingekauft würde ich sagen ich weiß
nicht ob es für meine typischen 7 kills
reicht ja ich weiß etwas typisches aber
ja leute ja auf jeden fall ich freue
mich richtig man ich möchte einfach mal
ganz ehrlich so mit euch reden erzählen
wie das eine so viel für mich ist
momentan berlin berlin wahrheit so viel
arbeit das habe ich nie gesagt aber ich
möchte auch mal sagen gerade weil die
wald so viel arbeit und jetzt endlich
beginnen so die wochen wo ich mal ein
bisschen van hab jetzt hab ich besuch
von zwei kumpels und ja mit ihnen
einkaufen heute unter anderem sneaker
schuhe und auch andere angelegenheiten
und die zeit heute im deathmatch würde
ich sagen hat was davon beginnt ja nur
ganz am schluss ja klar für jeden kennt
würde ich sagen allen ähnlichen
deathmatch eltern das recht sondern wie
sollen wir vor spielen zu dem popo für
alles gefasst haben
am früheren macht echte davon ja wir
machen ein chip stunden später so leute
da sind wir jetzt fertig angekauft und
ja ich hab mir viel gold meine
connection spinnt gerade bisschen ich
hab einfach 2 barren max ed4 komischen
weiß sie was ist das bisschen länger
aber wie klingt trotzdem hin also ich
hab 19 gold ja bis 19 grad nicht geht
ich habe schon die djs hast du die
revision lacht viel kaufen das zum bogen
zufällig resources capital doch gerade
im schon gekauft man wo ist er denn hin
wir bogen habe ich ein buch ich habe
einen bogen aber durch meine ok komisch
als leckerbissen uns glaube ich
vielleicht auch nicht verderblichen
gekauft was kann ich wissen ja im
team-quartier ist noch ganz viel in den
kopf wie viel fehlen ihr hatte alles gut
ich hab mir schon schwer
dank ihr hier
schnapp dir mal das ist ja auch noch
jemand ist desto besser liegt
wir müssen auch im zweiten bogen haben
bogen schafft man das was da liegt neben
dem shop das niveau
rahden aufpassen ok also die connection
ist auf jeden fall sehr crazy heart da
müssen wir aufpassen dass wir den 81
kommt peter maffay oder udo ist peter
maffay lassen müssen hätte man lieber
nicht angegriffen so okay jetzt erster
und wir fangen wir an mit dies nicht
wollten
diese jeans eine schwarze jeans hab ich
mir gekauft ich war heute ein bisschen
auf dem bleck trip assist lieber ist 511
tms konnten gegner aber nachziehen april
aus wales okay dass der erste einkauf
die siegerteams hier sehr nice dann
warte ich musste ein bisschen älter sie
unten
ich bin ziemlich lecker des todes alter
korrekt hätte mich ja ich komme ich hab
ihn hab ich hab ich nur junge junge
union als ob als ich wollte gerade
runter zu dir gelaufen da wird dann die
an die oberfläche zurück teleportiert
das ist nur ein lucky blog bgr jetzt
geht sogar halbwegs jetzt passen sie
sich so lange ab 1
partners und feiere aspects of bekommen
ps3 sword auch noch ich habe nun auch
ein start mit drei hier selbst ja du
kannst es übrigens kombinieren das und
firewire aspect und alles mögliche das
gibt ein ziemlich op kommission der
kommerner daran ändert dass michael das
nicht können
honig honig habe ich hab' ich habe ich
habe ihn ob es damit jetzt der zweite
stock wo haben wir es hier drüben leute
diese sneakers habe ich heute gekauft
die habe ich auch schon an gehabt das
sind new balance 996 in so schwartze
thema black weiterhin bin ich richtig
cool
die habe ich mir beim gipfel in berlin
gekauft es am schlesischen tor
alle die daherkommen wissen denn während
des essens oder wenn sie es nicht wissen
jesus und nicht mehr halt dann haltet
euren hatte alter kommt er kommt auch
nicht treffen
ich hab' ich habe die ganzen geschlagen
es ist nichts passiert ist dann
plötzlich habe ich irgendwie 1000 weil
ich hole mir ja ok damit der dritte 35
städten kommt soll ich nicht
der dritte akt einkauf sind diese sachs
lifestyle und die socken sind auch
vielleicht natürlich exakt juni zu viel
stoff gerade nächsten fünf sekunden
ok 321 nimmt die player herzen im
einkauf hinten kriegt einfach mein kopf
aber ja man kann keinen anstand
rudi healing oder displays warte warte
warte warte warte ich konnte und dann
allerdings spekulieren die boarder kommt
dollar kommt kurz mit den armen aki
blockiert amors wohl dein ernst herr
bastida ich hatte noch einen drin
ich würde sonst gegen teams auf jeden
fall
es kann hier den habe ich mir geholt ok
drei stücke ja
noch mal ein schwert kam raus dass
weiten von 134 perfekt poison alter
dobson und herrenhäusern und in
hamminger ins damaged jungen
ich muss erstmal ganz die ganze rüstung
ja die hessen besser so und haben wir
hier noch einmal ab und baute auch
roboter ist richtig namen hier nochmal
eine nochmal dreijährigen
forschungsprojekt wo ist der amboss hier
drüben
es sind nur noch drei spieler ich bin
mir sicher ob die anderen teams sind ich
weiß nicht ich muss aber erstmal sie
sind sie sind sie also passt auf jeden
fall auch vor gott ich hoffe meine
connection kit nicht das was du willst
sie ist aber ziemlich flüssig auf jetzt
mit der connections zweiten mal kurz weg
hätten gucken ob die kommen schärfe 4
hatte habe ich noch flächen gibt gas
gibt gas nice ich habe dir auf jeden
fall wollt ihr auch ein vom kostet jetzt
16 alter avp du musst die schwerter
vertauschen verbrennung 1 ist drin
stehen der mitte stehen damit mache ich
mir die alter energy schafft dann muss
noch zwei sachen vorstellten die junge
ohne witz als ich habe noch ein paar
weiß nicht was ich zeigen kann
ich muss mal kurz hier gucken kann ich
mir darüber noch was kaufen
ich komme mit meinen job dran ok lava
einmal hab ich so weit auch hier sind
noch zwei sie noch shops in der mitte
aber damit sind die wassereimer habe ich
en appel habe ich den bogen es hat nicht
so stark dass wir sind goldie essen
golden ja klar
die gab es wird richtig schwer gegen
zwei drückt ihn eine links sein direkt
ansetzen
sehr schön beide brennen aber sie lassen
sich aber haben sich ein bisschen
bekommt also ich würde definitiv links
rein drücken was am dienstag
ich habe die pause ja da kommt man
bekommt man ja ok aladag rummst du aber
weißrussen
ja was was was was wir denn was ist das
denn junge du jetzt ist es meine person
ist ihm stand halt immer noch da jung
galt
ich habe eine wachen connect okay leute
damit habe ich da kein killer gemacht
aber ich sage nochmal letzten einkauf
hier die labels die toiletten richtig
nice sehen vielleicht ein bisschen
komisch aussah hat dann so extrem nah
ist von irgendeinem roy robson oder so
ziemlich cool
das war alles die ganze challenge von
mir ich hoffe dadurch gefallen sodass
immer gezeigt habe was ich mir so
gekauft habe und übrigens ich gehe echt
nicht oft einkaufen
also ich hab mir glaub ich zum ersten
mal seit einem jahr schätzungsweise
klamotten gekauft
nein es soll sich so angeber mäßig rüber
kommen weil das bin ich eigentlich nicht
und ich bin ein sparsamer gut aber heute
muss man gemacht hat man die kommentare
was ihr davon haltet wir sehen uns im
nächsten video wieder haus rein was gut
und tschüss hoffentlich mit besseren
connection macht's gut